hey everyone this is jeremy with khan
academy um thanks so much for joining us
on this friday afternoon or friday
morning depending on where you're
calling it from
wherever you're calling in from you're
in for a special treat today because we
have matt one of our khan academy
ambassadors from georgia calling in to
share his expertise on using khan
academy with high schoolers
and while i think matt would have been
willing to offer this at any time i have
to give him special thanks for doing it
right now in the midst of this crisis
because matt like myself has two kids
running around at home and so matt's
actually taking this call from outside
his home just so we can have some peace
and quiet to devote to you all today
so as a quick reminder the way these
sessions work is we're gonna get to know
matt a little bit better get some of his
best tips for using khan academy at the
high school level
and then once we have that we're going
to open it up to questions from you
right from the audience so if you want
to submit those questions to matt just
go to the questions tab of the go to
webinar control panel and we'll take
those in the order they received so any
questions start submitting those now and
we'll take those very soon
but before we do again another shout out
to you matt for making time in your busy
day your busy teaching schedule your
busy home front life
and just kick things off why don't you
tell us a little bit about your
background as an educator and how you
got started with khan
absolutely and i i appreciate khan
academy for having me and
giving me this opportunity to to share
some things with you
so my name is matt colbruth um i've
spent seven years as a formal educator
i have a bachelor's degree from dalton
state college
with an education certification i am
about eight weeks out from having a
master's degree
in math education from thomas university
i spent my first three years after i
graduated
in chattanooga tennessee at a school
east hamilton middle high school i
taught 7th grade math i also taught 8th
grade algebra
and
served as the middle school boys
basketball coach and an assistant high
school basketball coach
in 2016 i moved to my current employment
with catoosa county schools in northwest
georgia
i spent my first year as a traveling
teacher between two schools lakeview
fort worth high school and ringgold high
school
after the first year
uh lakeview fort osawa had a
full-time position available i was a
halftime general ed math teacher and a
half time special ed math teacher and
that's what i've served for the last
three years
i've taught algebra 1 algebra 2 math of
finance
foundations of algebra
at the general ed and special ed levels
i serve as the assistant girls
basketball coach and an assistant
baseball coach i also am the algebra one
team facilitator for the our plc group
our professional learning community and
i serve on our response intervention
initiation team we're just now getting
our response intervention program
um kind of kicked off and so i i serve
on on that team as an active member
wow matt you were a man of many hats
done this for done this for a little
while and it's uh
it's just a joy to i mean i love being
an educator i think it goes back to
my
as a child i was one of the older of my
of my cousins and had a large family
close-knit family but i wanted to see
my younger sis my younger siblings my
younger cousins just wanted to see them
become the best that they could be and
and i still kind of hold that true
to now my students i just it's kind of
carried on as i guess my calling
very cool i know they need you more than
ever right now so thanks for all that
you're doing and just to sort of dive
into this question of using khan academy
in the midst of all this
how do you normally use khan academy how
do you typically integrate it into your
day to day
so
my students usually see some sort of
khan academy almost every day pretty
much every day
they
i at the beginning of the year i assign
them a
mastery challenge and
so with my algebra one class which is
typically what i teach
i will assign algebra 1 mastery the
course mastery usually in august early
august or in september
so when i do that that allows them to
see their progress and
and allows them to really work towards a
goal and we set bi-weekly goals to
uh
have them achieve that that course
mastery by the end of the year
um
so i i see you're kind of going through
some of the things to set up that course
mastery and it's once you get everything
set up it's really not a hard task but
it gives you so many things to be able
to see
uh how well your students are
progressing throughout the year
yeah and does this sort of explain for
teachers who are coming from more of an
assignments mindset to this mastery
mindset what is course mastery and like
why is it important
so through the course mastery it used to
be done with what they called missions
and we kind of moved into the course
mastery but the idea is that
everything especially mathematically
everything is built upon each other that
you have to have good foundations before
you can begin building on top of that
i've heard sal say in some of his ted
talks that if you're building a house
you you don't have an inspector come in
and say oh well that you know your
foundation's it's got 80 it's eight
percent half as code you know we can
start building the first level in the
second level eventually that crashes
down so the idea of course mastery is
that
you work through
uh different units and different lessons
and different levels of whatever subject
it is for instance for algebra 1
it begins with an algebra foundations
piece
unit and you work through that algebra
foundations unit
and
you gain points for assignments that you
complete and questions that you answer
correctly and
and you continue moving through that
unit until you've completed it it has
some quizzes available in it it has a
unit test available for each unit and
as i said students earn points every
time they complete these with accuracy
and they will level up and eventually
get to that mastery point absolutely so
basically what you're setting out at the
beginning of the regular school year is
hey we have a high bar not just to get
through the textbook but to master each
foundational skill along the way and
course mastery kind of drives them to
that high bar
now let me sort of switch gears a little
bit that's all well and good if
september and if it's normal times
now that it's april and it's the strange
new world that we're living in
if you were just starting with khan
academy as a high school teacher today
what are the like one or two things you
would do just to get a quick win next
week just to get some wind behind your
back
well i think the first thing that you
need to do is be able to set up your
classes
and so when you sign in as a when you
sign up as a teacher
you will see this screen as this is kind
of your teacher dashboard and so to set
up your class
we're lucky in catoosa county that we
are
we all have google classrooms and so
khan academy does sync directly we'll
pull in rosters from
google classroom and so all you have to
do is click on the add new class
and uh if you have google classroom you
can actually import your class directly
from google classroom
and your rosters are automatically
put into
put into khan academy and so you don't
really have to do a whole lot if you
don't have the google classroom already
set up and you can you know enter your
class name and then you are asked to add
courses for your class for instance mine
is algebra 1 and i do typically go back
and maybe add like a pre-algebra
course to it just so i can see those
whenever i'm making assignments
see those lessons
so but you can choose whatever courses
you like mathematics or or anything
and then to add your students like i
said for google classroom users it's
very very simple just connect to your
google classroom
they can also use the class they can
share a link with their students and
their students can click on that link
and um
they will be able to they will
automatically be joined
i have i've been using khan academy for
years and years
and so when i was doing middle school i
would used to create the student
accounts for them because this was
before i had any sort of google
classroom and so i would create the
students accounts
put their names in it would give me a
username and a password and i would
share that with the students and they i
thought they would get on khan academy
that's great so multiple ways to get
started and then just sort of take this
through to the next step like let's say
you've built out your class you've
invited your students
what do you do to just sort of get a
little bit of expertise under the
student's belt
so um the the assignments tab i do use
quite often uh so uh when you click on
the class and you get into the screen
that you're in under the assignments and
you click to assign it has the entire
course uh every unit and everything
built underneath that and so you can
assign an entire unit as as uh jeremy's
done here he's clicked on the the check
mark and you can assign entire units uh
if you don't want the entire unit if you
just want to chunk it which is what i
typically do you may find a lesson that
will assign a few videos or a few um a
few practice assignments
or you may just want to assign one one
practice assignment and those are
indicated with the pencil mark over on
the left hand side you can click on the
assignment to see what kind of questions
it's actually going to be asking uh and
make sure that that is what you want and
one of the great things in my opinion
that the assignments the exercises do is
generally i don't believe there's any
exercise that has more than seven or
eight questions in it and so it's
nothing that is overwhelming to the
student you get and they're good quality
questions so you get a good idea of what
your student does know or doesn't know
but it's not going to take them an hour
and a half to complete
so
once you once you've decided what you
want to assign you click on the assign
button
and you you have some different options
there you can have that each student
does a different set of questions uh
most of the questions i've seen banks uh
upwards around 40 and 50 questions in
each step
or you could have all students do the
same questions there's been a lot of
times that i've had students do the same
questions
for the fact that
i can have them either do that at the
end of class or for homework something
of that nature and then later in the
class or the next day
we can come in and we use that their
information how they've answered those
questions and we talk about you know why
this was a good answer why this was a
bad answer and it's not just uh it's not
just to give me a
number grade to put in the grade book
very cool well
okay go go for it uh matt
oh i'm sorry so uh the other great thing
that i like under this screen is that
under the students tab you can select to
send it to all students but there have
been many times where i've wanted to
maybe differentiate or some students
have mastered a certain skill and i may
only choose you know a few students two
three students to send a um
an assignment to and especially we we
use this a lot with our rti program
we use the map test and uh use concat
the way khan academy links to it so
there's a lot of times where not every
student needs that assignment so i will
only assign to a few students
beautiful and then you can set your due
date and your time
so it goes out to the students what do
the students see can you talk a little
bit about that experience absolutely so
um if you go back to the to the top or
to the teacher dashboard
uh back to so at your home you can click
on your username or your name at in the
top right hand corner and it will show
you the learner home and so under
learner home that's what that kind of
gives you a view of what the students
are going to see
and when the students log into khan
academy once you have given an
assignment or you have given a course
mastery on the left-hand side
all of their assignment all of their
classes so they can't have they can be
enrolled in multiple classes um i know
our world history teacher has just
recently started using khan academy
quite a bit
for his class so beyond the math
classroom and uh their assignments and
their classes all show up on the left
hand side they will if they have a
course master goal that the course
mastery shows up there also the
assignments show up there and if the
assignment is past due
it shows up under the past tab if it's
still an active assignment then it would
obviously show up under the active
assignments tab
and so a student clicks into an
assignment that says mr colberth has
just assigned to me
they see it on their screen and how do
you typically recommend that students
use this like do they just go through in
one shot do they do it multiple times
they get support
it's very very i think this is one of
the toughest things to get across the
students is using some of the supports
that khan academy offers
i started using khan academy way back
when it was just youtube videos
and the videos are some of the best help
that i think the students can get
if i can get them to use it so under
whenever they give it their best try and
they don't get a question right they can
get help and they have either hints
available to them or video content that
is available to them and
um
i'll even tell students if you've missed
one or two questions
even if you try your first time or you
don't try you just have no idea what it
is use that those videos use those hints
to help you understand the material
they're reluctant to do that because
they don't like to get questions wrong
but i tell them if you can learn it
then learning it is much more important
than one correct answer
absolutely so definitely lean on khan
academy to give that live real-time
feedback even if you can't be there to
give it yourself
um and then just sort of bring it full
circle back to the teacher view
um we'll take questions from the
audience in one second
once your students have started to
complete these exercises where are you
looking to sort of understand what's
happening
yeah so um
in the classroom on the classroom page
uh you have to
under the assignments there's a tab for
scores so you'll click on the scores tab
and it will give you the scores for each
student uh whichever assignments you
have
so you can look at that and then if you
want to look at individual reports you
can click on the actual score for that
student
so you can when you click on the score
it will show you what questions they've
attempted uh how they answered them
which ones they got correct which one
they got uh wrong and i know up at the
for the attempt
a lot of times i will look at their
first attempt to see kind of how they
answered it to begin with and what their
initial thinking was and then their last
attempt is really how they
completed the question
the other place that the other place
that i have i've started recently using
and this is fairly new new to me
is under the classroom page is the
activity overview
and here you can look at
how much time students are spending on
khan academy
what skills are they practicing you know
how many skills are they leveling up and
you can also look at individual students
look at really the activities they're
doing on khan academy so when you click
on that student's name it will show you
a lot more in-depth information about
what the student is doing on khan
academy you can also see individual
student assignments from that page
and um
and the time they're spending as well
that's great so i think that's probably
more than enough for a week or two of
just getting adjusted to khan academy
let's pause there in the interest of
sort of the reality of the situation
because i know you could go on to
probably three hours of in-depth
advanced tips let's just take the
questions from the audience and see
where people's minds are at
so first question is coming in from
belinda
and belinda asks a really important
question that sort of goes beyond the
technology
what are your suggestions matt for how
to handle progress for students who are
not doing assignments even over extended
periods i know we're in very very
unusual times now but how would you
recommend handling you know a student
who's just not making any progress on
khan academy
well
i think
one of the things is the communication
between
between the teacher and the student and
so during a normal time if i see that
students are not making progress i i
have a conference with with that student
i talk with that student and i think
there is a um
you know khan academy is not a a
babysitter it's not and it's not a
replacement for me i still have that
relationship with the student and i i
speak with them to try to motivate find
that motivation for you know why is this
important why do you need this
what kind of correlation does it have to
your life
and now during these times i still
am trying to find ways to communicate
with students whether it be through
uh email messages or through
i use an app for mind app that allows me
to send messages via text
to students and so i still try to find
those ways to communicate and
you know really drill down the
importance of the assignments and
hopefully
use my relationship with them to to
drive that forward
great great yeah i think even in these
extenuating circumstances
communication with students is still the
key to pretty much all great teaching
and even if it's communication over an
app or a video conference or whatever
reaching out beyond just hey here's an
assignment it's so important um speaking
of that sandy sandy has a question for
you that kind of extends that question
what if you have students who are not
only struggling with grade level
material but actually have big gaps in
their foundations they're already coming
to you in high school many years behind
is there any opportunity to use khan to
help catch them up
absolutely and i'm glad you said that
because one of the great things that
that we've been doing at lfo that i'm
very proud of is our rti program our
response to intervention program and if
you try to research uh and find many
resources on high school rti programs
there's not a lot out there we couldn't
find any so uh
khan academy uh in a partnership with
nwea and map testing uh is one thing
that we have used this year and so we we
gave our students a map assessed the map
assessment at the beginning of the year
which kind of diagnoses and tells us
exactly where they're at and we have
students all the way you know coming
into ninth grade all the way down
on a fourth and fifth grade late grade
level um on certain math skills and so
we set up
little classes for them during our
guided studies time really during our
flex time and um
we we used khan academy to reach back
into those fourth and fifth grade uh
concepts and
re-teach and try to solidify that
because as we said if you do not have
the um
if you don't have those foundations it's
hard to build off of it so we would find
we we used the data that we gathered
from the map test to identify what
content we needed to focus on for those
students and
then use khan academy to help teach and
and assess students on that those
concepts
i love that it's such a powerful sort of
way to like make sure that each student
is getting what they need not just
whatever your pacing guide is telling
you today
did you use the mappers tool out of
curiosity matt
i i certainly did so um if you just
i searched mappers um and really it's
it'll pop right right there it is um
and so
when you go in your classes if your
classes are already set up
you can enter the map scores if you have
used the map test
and you enter the map scores for
for the data that you have for the
students that you have and then it will
give you a recommendation for what what
concepts those students need to be
working on
very cool
um so i've just pasted that link into
the chat box so if anyone is using the
map assessment in their school they can
definitely take advantage of that um
here's another important question about
differentiation
christina says for special education
students at the high school level how do
we make accommodations
would you recommend like you know making
special worksheets for them pulling
these questions out of that academy how
do you serve that audience in particular
uh so
a lot of times it's um
i limit the number of questions or the
number of assignments that i do with
them
we do a lot really just as a as a class
so we may uh present questions up on the
board
as a class and then kind of walk through
that altogether
not not as much as an independent
activity
uh i also have a limited use of ipads
and one thing that a lot of i found that
a lot of my students like to do
is uh use the ipads because they can
touch it and they can
draw on it and they can the khan academy
app allows you to use a pencil tool and
actually you know show some work on it
and it for whatever reason it does tend
to engage the students a little bit more
um
i i think that
there are certain accommodations that
you can provide there but again i will
interject and say the teacher is
probably the most important tool that
you have so using the things that you
know and the strategy that you have to
blend the two you know between khan
academy and the things that you are
doing in the classroom are you know
crucial to
to that sort of intervention
[Music]
my apologies uh there are just sort of
showing off
one way to sort of draw even if you
don't have fancy technology
in that assignment score report that
matt had talked about a couple minutes
ago
you could actually share the screen on a
zoom call or google hangout call with
your students
and walk through live you know how you
might solve a problem step by step so
just another way to build that
communication line
to your students
um let me ask another really important
question from bryce
bryce says how do you typically grade
matt do you take scores from con to
account do you build your own
assessments how does con fit into that
uh great question because uh we've been
having this discussion at our school uh
about grading and and what grades should
look like uh extensively here recently
so
um our our subject area our algebra one
teachers have recently decided that we
are grading
um for the most part on course mastery
so based on the assessments that we give
and the and uh whether that be through
chronic formative assessment through
khan academy or a paper and pencil
assessment uh unit tests we we take
those grades and we
uh
basic whatever our learning target is we
base it on a scale of one to four
whether it's one being a beginning level
learner or four being a master level
learner or somewhere in between
so and that makes up 70 of our our
grading process so
there could be some times where the khan
academy like i said fits as a
formative assessment but a lot of time
most of it i use for the other 30
percent my daily grades
that i take and i use
i use the grades that they have made on
the assignments but i allow unlimited
number of attempts because i don't
i'm not worried that a student doesn't
know it on monday
if they know it on friday of that same
week or if even if it takes them two
weeks to learn it
my goal is by the time they leave my
class that they understand the material
and the content that i'm wanting to
teach
regardless of how long it takes them to
learn that
i love that yeah and i've heard that
from so many other educators recently
the khan academy is not about
whether you're you know quote unquote um
you know getting an a or a b
but whether you have that growth mindset
are you constantly pushing yourself
towards that mastery goal even if it's a
really long stretch for you and so using
that to sort of look at the progress
they're making can be even more
important um
really important question from sandy
sandy says hey you know if we're trying
to figure out where our students are
they've obviously been away from their
regular routines for a little while and
want to do maybe some kind of baseline
diagnostic
is there any way to do something similar
to that in khan academy just to get a
sense of where students are at right now
um i i would say that's a good question
and i i may not know a perfect answer to
it one thing i have used
uh to
maybe as like i have used as a pre-test
is the
course challenges or the unit tests
within each of the subject areas
so
say we were in a unit of quadratics
before we left
for our extended break and so i used out
under the quadratic unit at the very
bottom there's a unit test and you can
assign that unit test and it will cover
everything that's within that unit and
you can see what questions uh students
get right and get wrong
that's great yeah i think that's just
the easiest way to quickly figure out
what are the skills that they're lacking
where they are
and then pinpoint as you make those
differentiated assignments as matt
talked about that's great
um
let's see here
this is a sort of a basic question about
just making sure that assignments are on
target ayami wants to know matt is there
any way to change the due date of an
assignment after i assign it
great question because i've done this
multiple times many many times uh yes so
under the assignment tab
uh when you go to ma instead of the
assigner scores you can go to manage
and uh on the far right hand side you
can uh click the actions and the edit
button
and that will allow you to change if you
want to add students
to that you can do that and again
there's the change the due date
and the time
and uh you click save changes and those
changes will be made
another probably similar question is
that what happens when students when you
have a new student come in we're a very
transient uh school and so i had
multiple times where i had a new student
come in
and so uh i would add them to my google
classroom and then resync on khan
academy under the settings tab
uh you can reset update sync with google
classroom
once that is done when you go back to
the assignments tab it will it will give
you a prompt uh asking if you want to
reassign the assignments that are active
currently to the new students and so you
all you have to do is click save or yes
and uh it will allow you to reassign
or give those assignments to the new
student walking in
cool
and then another really sort of
important foundational question from
phil
okay so i'm curious to do these
assignments but i want to actually
understand what i'm assigning before i
give it out is there some way for me the
teacher to view the course or view the
exercise before it goes out to my
students
absolutely so um under the assigns
the sign tab you can scroll through the
the entire course as we had said before
uh the videos if you click on the link
for the videos it will take you directly
to that and you can watch the video
uh in its entirety for the um
practice the exercises and the articles
you can view the article by clicking on
the tab and for the exercises it shows
you the complete set of list of
questions
to see what that would look like and
then you can also click on the student
view to see what this what it will look
like for the student
another thing on the assignments is that
i've had a lot of teachers
who
don't necessarily
for whatever reason they don't like
looking through
that the entire list for a specific
thing that they know that they want to
assign so they will use the search bar
up at the very top
and
they may search
quadratic yeah quadratic equations and
once they find so they know exactly what
they want to assign to their students
they just need to find it and they'll
use that search bar they'll find the
exercise that they want to use
and they will click on it
and i've used this quite often too the
tab at the top now allows you to assign
that specific assignment to the to
students through that method once you
see it on your screen once you see the
student view on your screen um so you
can still have the same options and
assign it that direct in that way
i love that because i feel like it can
be totally overwhelming to look at that
massive list of skills and videos on the
course but if you just want one skill or
one video
search for that thing you want and then
click the blue bar to go right to the
assignment piece
okay i know we're running out of time so
i want to finish up with three questions
starting with a really great one that i
received from rose an eighth grader so
again these webinars are promoted very
broadly um rose says i'm an eighth
grader who's getting ready for high
school next year and i'm worried with
this whole thing happening
you know in school being closed how can
i be ready how can i prepare
as a high school teacher speaking to a
future high schooler what advice would
you give rose for really making sure
she's ready for prime time hopefully
knock on wood come september
yeah well first i would say rose could
you uh if you want to move to northwest
georgia and come to my classroom it
sounds like you're a great student so
that that is awesome but you're
concerned with it but uh using khan
academy
my suggestion would be to go into the
the courses in the top left hand corner
and choose uh
that you know in our school we move into
algebra one so if you're moving into
algebra one uh select the course that
you were wanting to do
or that you're going to be moving into
and begin
begin at that first unit and and work
your way through it uh
use the videos as a help like i said i
started with khan academy with the on
the on youtube and uh using videos to
help me
kind of solidify the things that i was
hearing in class but even as a first
instruction uh those videos they're
great instructional videos and i highly
recommend them uh to walk watch through
them and then practice your exercises
and one thing that we have not touched
on is the um
the mastery challenges that are are
somewhat new to khan academy
so whenever you click on that course
page
at the top you will receive a mastery
challenge a lot of times i have my
students do that
maybe as a warm-up when they come in in
the morning
or uh throughout the day when they
finish an assignment to go work on their
course math their mastery challenge and
this is just a spiral review for all the
things that you have covered to uh just
re-revisit and make sure you've not
forgotten the things that you have done
through on khan academy
all right great advice for rose and
rosie wish you good luck i know it's a
hard time right now but thank you for
joining us and um i have a feeling that
they're awesome mr culver's in your
future in high school so more support to
come
um second question for you matt is i
know we haven't been able to cover every
question that came in right now
if educators are still hungry for
answers after the session where would
you recommend they go next
so a couple of different places that
that i would say one is um
first i would say under on your teacher
dashboard i've directed a lot of
teachers this uh
to this point is the resources tab
and there's a lot of good videos
underneath that resources tab especially
for getting started um so if you're
really new to it and you want to look at
some different things you know check
check all of those out
if you run into like a specific question
or something that you need to ask
underneath your name in the top right
hand corner
there is when you click on it there is a
help
help section so you can click on that
help section and your
questions are sent directly to
khan academy experts who who get back to
you quite quickly
you just have to report the problem at
the top
and i've had good experience with that
the last area that i would recommend
everyone joining is a facebook page and
it is khan academy for teachers
and and i'm a member there and uh tend
to
i look at it almost daily and uh just
see some of the conversations that are
going on there but there are a
bajillion uh great khan academy teachers
that use khan academy on there that can
answer a lot of great questions a lot of
questions that you have
all right awesome i'm just sharing all
those resources in the chat so if you
want to get the resources if you want to
get the request help from khan academy
or join the facebook group all that is
in your chat and then lastly that i know
that you've already shared a ton but if
you have any final words of wisdom for
educators out there across the country
as we're thinking about oh my goodness
i've got at least a couple more weeks to
go probably many more than that
how do i make the most of this time how
do i support my students and their
families
any sort of stage advice you can share
i have just one tried to not get
overwhelmed by it all you know make sure
you're taking care of yourself and
taking care of uh
your immediate family first because
if you are not in good health and
there's no way you can help anyone else
so take care of yourself but two just
try to keep it some sort of a
communication line open with your
students i think that is uh the most
important thing that students can know
that you are there that you are
available to them and um
and the content will start to once they
have that relationship and they they
know that you're you're looking out for
their best interest the the content side
of it starts to kind of fall in place
i love that yeah it's almost like the
advice you give to new parents you've
got to take care of yourself before you
can take care of your kids and the same
is doubly true for educators
so absolutely um
matt has given us tons of new wisdom
to pursue these big challenges we have
ahead of us it's also given us the
strength to do it um at a time when we
need it the most so i want to thank you
matt for sharing all your expertise
today and i want to thank everyone out
there listening in for investing in the
session and i wish you tremendous
success in the weeks to come thank you
so much and have a great weekend all
thank you all